you'll never win doing work that you
hate you'll never crush it on your
podcast if you show up every day and you
don't like the podcast you don't like
the guest you don't like what you're
doing which means you have to Pivot it
may mean you I don't know the back story
behind stopping we do hard things and
moving to to the what's the new sales
one called what's this one called to
sore how to sellmore right great this's
a story right I mean at some point you
stopped liking doing that it wasn't
working or or it ran out of time
whatever but it wasn't okay that's it
I'm done all podcasting I'm never
talking to anybody again I'm just going
to go and do something else like no I'm
going to launch a new show and so
everything has a time in place but yeah
if I look at my calendar and I and I'm
consistently not liking when something
shows up then you have to move on cuz
you're not going to win doing work that
you hate need motivation watch a top 10
with belief Nation hey it's S car
Michael and I make these videos because
I need them because being around
successful entrepreneurs who are pushing
who are driving who are doing amazing
things gives me that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning every day to help me go off and
accomplish great things too and I hope
that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's learn
from one of the best my husband Evan
carmichel in our take on his top 10
rules for Success
enjoy it's so easy to complain and and
it's a default mode it's nice to think
that it's the president's fault that
you're not successful or your mom's
fault or the school system's fault or
you don't have enough money or whatever
it's nice to think that that's the
reason and what that does is by blaming
somebody else it puts you in an
unresourceful state it means it's not
your fault so you don't have to fix it
it's your mom's fault M it's the
president's fault right it's their fault
so I'm G to complain and be angry about
it but I don't have to do anything about
it because it's not my fault so it's
when you say okay this is actually my
responsibility it may not be your fault
but it's your responsibility to fix it
that I can get I can get out of this
what that does at the start is well that
sucks you know it's because it's so nice
to be able to blame somebody now they're
SU sucks that it's on me to go off and
fix it but then it's also the ultimate
power and that you can change your
circumstances you can change your
situation you can make it better just by
saying it's on me to fix it like there's
no Cavalry coming by by kicking the
president out of office it doesn't
change your situation you know so so
stop waiting for something else to
happen like you are in charge uh and so
for for any spot in life like you were
you are where you are because of you and
I have a test that I call the mirror
test where you walk in the mirror go
into the bathro or wherever you have a
mirror and ask yourself why am I not
more
successful why have I not hit my goals
and whatever the first thing that comes
back when you look in the mirror those
are the excuses that you need to bust
through right because you something's
going to come up that's an excuse It's a
story you're holding on to I don't have
the right parents or I don't go to the
right school or I don't know how to be
charismatic or whatever it's some it's
always some excuse um and that's the one
that you need to work on immediately to
fix so you can go build that better life
for yourself the first person I hired
was was not in this YouTube business but
but way back in my first company and it
was for one hour a day and I hired him
to do one hour of work a day because it
freed up about an hour and a half of my
time per day and I think honestly as
soon as you can you want to get somebody
to help out it does a couple things one
it it it really helps to not be doing
this alone like it really sucks to do
everything all by yourself just the
emotional I mean you guys have each
other which is
great like join a group join a community
don't be alone because it's really
really really hard to be an entrepreneur
and do it all on your own when all of
those insecurities and fears and doubts
and like I'm not good enough and I was
so dumb for starting this and what was I
thinking and right uh so it's it's nice
to have somebody who's doing this with
you as opposed to you doing it all by
yourself plus it's just Smart in that
you don't have to do all the work that
you can delicate some of the tasks away
to focus on whatever is you know more
inside of your passion and what you love
and what you can you know charge more
for as well to build your company I
expect to fail all the
time I expect everything I do especially
at the beginning to not work right if
I'm launching something new I just don't
expect it to do well at the beginning
because it's because creativity is messy
and people put this label Perfection on
it I want it to be perfect but you don't
even know how to make it yet so just get
it out there I value the momentum more
than the
Perfection and so I don't if you're
looking to believe that it's going to
work out that's a big picture macro
concept that any video that I make on my
YouTube channel may not work and if it's
a brand new thing I expected not to work
but it's the belief that if I keep going
it will will eventually work right that
I'll figure it out that I'll adjust that
I'll learn something and I'll prove the
next one so I think people need to give
themselves permission to fail at the
beginning for it not to work out and to
not take that personally doesn't mean
that you suck just because your first
song didn't hit it big just means you
learned a little bit and keep going and
if you keep making new songs and every
day you're practicing and trying to get
better eventually it will work out and I
just fully believe
that I can do it that you can do it that
everybody watching and listening can do
it people just quit too soon and they're
trying to be too perfect until they
never get to where they need to be I
think the the ultimate resource is your
ability to be resourceful um the line
that comes to mind is from Steve wnc who
co-founded Apple who said stop thinking
about all the things that you don't have
and instead think about what you can do
with what you do have and I think that's
uh an important line for any
entrepreneur it's easy to look at the
million reasons why you're not going to
win there's a million reasons why you
will not win and and you know Gary and I
can sit down and bring some a million
more reasons why you're not going to win
uh but there's like eight why you will
and so all I do is focus on those eight
and be as resources as possible on those
eight you don't even now if I'm trying
to build my business you know I have 24
people on my team I've had success with
what I'm doing but I don't have a
thousand people on my team and I can sit
and complain around how I don't have a
thousand people or I can say well I have
24 what can I do with my 24 and that's
always the mindset think about what you
can do with what you do have and
understand that whoever your heroes are
whoever you look up to whoever your role
models are in life whoever's had massive
success chances are they started with
less than what you already have right
now whether you looking at Oprah or
Richard Branson or whoever it is they
started with less than what you already
have right now and so if they could do
it you can too the only difference is
your willingness to be resourceful we
know what we sell perfect let's use
social media to help us sell more of our
stuff like the the big reason why people
quit is because you feel like you're
wasting time making content and it's not
Genera any sales for you and I'm Mission
first purpose first if anybody is
familiar with my content what I do it's
like purpose first and you have to make
money because if you're not making money
you're going to quit on the thing so how
can we make money inside our purpose
instead of having to have some job
that's outside our purpose right so the
next thing to think about if you know
what you're selling or what you are
looking to sell right next is who are
referral partners for us so actually KS
if you look at your business like who
are the types of people who refer
clients to you humans are built to serve
because if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not
serving and that's that's hardwired into
US serving others helping others hits
the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so it's it's
literally hardwired into you that you
want to you feel good by serving other
people so if you're not happy right now
you mentioned the word depression if
you're depressed and you're not happy
you're not serving either the world
maybe you have a big mission or big
Vision or the 25 closest people to you
you don't have to have some giant
Mission but you have to feel like you're
serving the people who are closest to
you either one if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving and so the
good news is you can always figure out a
way to serve exactly exactly and you can
serve on a on a you know really deep
level which is what the book gets into
of how to figure out how to how to serve
exactly but even just doing an act of
kindness even just doing one nice thing
for somebody else will will make you
feel better ultimately what I want
people to do is if you woke up and you
felt like today
mattered like you woke up this morning
and you felt like today mattered you're
G to make something today that matters
you're gonna you're going to create
something today whether that's a song or
a video or artwork like you're creating
when you're creating something that has
the potential to impact somebody else's
life if you did that every day you're
you're on a path to happiness I think
everybody has an agenda for you uh your
parents your friends your family your
kids like everybody has an agenda for
you and if you don't understand what
your agenda is for yourself then you'll
just be pulled in a thousand different
directions and never accomplish anything
that you actually want to go off and
accomplish and so chances are whatever
the thing is that you have greatness in
whatever you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at uh it's going to make some
people upset you know even out of love
like saying that you want to go off and
do this but uh your parents don't think
that that's the right thing for you or
or nobody in your family has ever done
it it's easy for them to pull you down
and prevent you from going off and doing
the thing that you actually want to do
and so the common trait of everybody
who's had massive success is being able
to deal with the people around them
telling them that their idea suck that
it's never going to work and you still
get up and you go and you do it anyway
for a lot of people the advice that your
parents are giving you is out of love
they love you they just see success
differently they grew up in a different
world and so success to them looks one
way and you're off doing this crazy
other path and so they just care about
you and they're trying to do the best
thing that they think is for you but the
the worst advice you can give somebody
is what you would do in a
situation that's the worst advice you
can give them here's what I would do
well who cares what you would do you're
not me right like never get like the
best advice you give is try to
understand that person and give them the
answer that will help them even if it's
not the same thing that you would do and
so I think a lot of people that's the
real trouble spot where there's people
who love you who are trying to help you
and they think they're helping you but
they're not um because that's what they
would do the thing that anyone who
follows you online will say is that you
are definitely consistent how much do
you think that has played into the
success that you have today I think a
lot I was doing an interview earlier
today and uh somebody was saying that I
was really bold like you're such a bold
courageous person I'm like really I
don't know I don't feel that bold but I
am consistent we started in 2009 and I
don't think I've missed an upload in a
decade and so you know tons of videos
just consistently going up so uh yeah
I'm the guy who did not start super well
at the beginning I had 25 subscribers in
year one and 2,000 subscribers in year
five and I fast forward today and you
know I've had a lot more success since
then but just waking up every day and
doing the work and amazing things can
happen I think we want to progress we
want to grow we want to learn we want to
improve I think if there's nothing in
your calendar that scares you that
doesn't give you a little bit of anxiety
Then I think you hate your life it means
you're just doing the same thing over
and over and over and over and over
again there's nothing new you don't like
your life if you're not progressing and
learning and growing um so anytime you
have
that idea of something that you want to
do and then your heart's beating and
you're you're nervous I I think that's
go time I think that means you have to
go start it and try to chase it down and
constantly battle the the lack of belief
and the voices in your head to go do the
next thing I I think it's I think
anybody who doesn't have that is not
doing anything big and is not
challenging them themselves to
grow most entrepreneurs spend way too
much time doing things that barely
matter you're working hard you're
grinding every day it's not that you're
not trying it's that you're spending
your time doing activities that are not
moving the business forward enough we
need to play bigger and focus on the
right things because you cannot be in
the same spot that you're in today one
year from now this video is going to
help so I've got a friend of mine going
through this right now an entrepreneur
she's she's an amazing entrepreneur I
want to see her win so badly and and she
has this very clear path for what she
needs to do very clear you have to do
this you got to talk to these people
this will move the ball forward this is
all you need to be spending your time on
reach out to these 50 people and you
will start to accomplish
success and she's afraid she's afraid
that she doesn't have the answers she's
afraid that it's not going to work out
she's afraid they're not going to pick
up the phone she's afraid she's just
afraid and so she's consuming herself
with busy work she's consuming herself
with tasks that do move the ball but in
tiny little increments that poting on
social media and that touching base with
somebody on the team and that logging
into the CRM all these things that
probably should happen but aren't really
differen makers for her business that's
what she's spending her time doing so
she can Pat herself on the back and say
look at me I'm busy I'm doing work I'm
I'm crushing I went in and I checked
everything off my list today except the
thing that mattered most except the
thing that will actually push your
business forward and everybody around
her this is likely a challenge for you
everybody around
her is is looking to her as a leader is
looking to her as this ambitious
go-getter working hard person nobody
around her is saying listen what you're
spending your time on is ridiculous is
not where you need to be putting your
efforts and so she's stuck in this in
this plain small mode in this land of
excuses where yes she's being massively
productive but she's not doing enough to
move her business forward and one year
from now she's going to be in a similar
spot slightly ahead because she was too
afraid to take action on the things that
she needs to take action on but now
she's got me and I'm on her every day to
say how we doing on that list how we
doing on that list how and suffocating
the excuses cuz I'm not buying the
excuses cuz I know she's capable of more
cuz I'm not going to allow any out
possible because everybody in her life
everybody in your life might be letting
you off the hook thinking you're out
there working hard doing the right
things but you are
not and you need either the
self-discipline to do it or somebody
amazing in your life to say say I am not
allowing you to play small anymore it's
okay to be afraid it's not okay to let
that fear stop you because until you
start focusing on the things that will
actually grow your business forward you
will never accomplish the success that
you are after if you are doing something
new you are going to get rejected if
you're doing something that you're not
good at yet you are going to get
rejected if you're doing something that
goes against the status quo you are
going to get rejected so you have two
choices live a life with zero growth and
never get rejected or chase your dream
deal with the rejection that comes and
go change the world I have rejection all
the time in my life from Little
rejections of making videos that don't
pop to bigger rejections of projects
that I care deeply about that just don't
fly and people don't accept at the
beginning I look I look at this built to
serve this is a great example buil to
serve is my new book this book I'm
insanely proud of I think it's
life-changing I mean it should be I
think the work that you create should be
lifechanging but I poured so much into
this and I think people need to read it
like I I desperately think that this
book will change a lot of people's lives
it could change your life I I believe
it's not just hyperbole like I I truly
fundamentally believe it when I came up
with the idea I was on my tour earlier
this year and I did not have time to
write it right I I was on my Tour on
behind on everything million things
being thrown at me meeting people doing
my events seeing the cities and it just
I just decided I have to write this book
because of all the feedback I was
getting from people it was all the
one-on ones I was doing with people the
same questions kept coming up how do I
find my purpose how do I know who I am
how do I turn into a business and so
that's the that's the point of the book
figuring out what your purpose is and
how to use that to then serve the world
right it's called buil the
serve and make it into a business so you
can make money doing it and build a team
and go off and live your mission when I
first pitched my publisher on it they
didn't want it they didn't want my book
right so uh your one word is down here
that's with penguin random house and
penguin passed so they had first my
first deal with u penguin Random House
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book so as soon as I get my next
book they get the right to look at it
first before I give it to anybody else
right so that's why I signed so like
okay here we go let's go it's a perfect
fit it I mean it follows really nicely
with your one word let's go right and
they said uh no we're GNA pass like yeah
what how do you pass this is better than
your one word I mean I love your one
word it's great but this is this is this
is the whole thing how do you pass on
this um it's just and we had to wait
because it's 30 days and all these
anyway legal stuff um so then we started
looking at other companies we started
looking at other publishing houses and
there were other ones that seemed to
line up really well with the content
that they had the the the author lineup
that they had and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right uh said
no and I mean like I got a I got a big
YouTube channel we have momentum we
already have our first book we're like
why why and all sorts of different
reasons you know um just not not doing
personal development books anymore not
whatever uh nobody came out and said
like we hate you Evan so maybe hopefully
that's not the reason um and then we
found one that that picked it up I like
okay
let's go and if if that one didn't pick
it up then then we would have kept
looking for more Publishers or I would
have just made it myself just
self-publish it put it out right what do
you do when the people around you don't
accept what you have when you want to
take something in a New Direction I
could have done something else I could
have done something easier if I just did
a a book about Jack ma right and his
rules for Success that would be easier
to pick up than this which I talk about
on the channel but it's not the main
thesis of the channel but that's what I
want to make make and that's what I'm
going to make whether it's I get a
publisher or we're going to you know
create it myself it's going to be
birthed into existence because I decided
so and just taking that mindset and
approach you have to if you love the
thing if you're doing something
different then you have to keep going
when people say that I don't want to
pick it up that it sucks that it's
stupid that you're maybe it's even a
great idea but you're not the person
who's going to do it right you have to
keep going I'm really
introverted it doesn't come across right
but I am I'm really introverted uh I
don't talk to people on the airplane
next to me is is Justin in the house
there's Justin so I sat next to Justin
on the airplane on the way down so
usually I just tell it as a theoretical
example but I actually sat next to
somebody on the airplane Justin and he's
trying to make small talk and uh I
wasn't trying to be rude just I Small
Talk makes me anxious like gives me
crazy anxiety and so I remember
everything he said I remember he woke up
at 4:00 a.m. to catch a 6 a.m. flight to
to get in at 2 a.m. here with me he
likes his coffee decaf with one sugar
and one
cream he has a a black leather Tumi bag
and so like I remember all this stuff
but we didn't really talk like that's
pretty much all we talked about on this
five hour flight down from New York to
here and so I I I'm just get super
anxious when doing small talk and
networking uh at the same time I'm I'm
scared to make videos so on my YouTube
Channel right now have you guys watch
some of my videos on YouTube okay decent
all right um I've got 6,000 videos
recorded on my YouTube channel 2 million
subscribers 300 million views all
organic I'm the organic guy these guys
are pros at paid ads I'm not fantastic
at that but organic I'm I'm your guy and
I still get afraid to turn on the camera
and press
record 6,000 videos later because
because I want to be an icon too and I
want to get my message out and every
video that I make I want it to be the
best I've ever done but I'm still afraid
to go out and make the content being on
stage always gives me crazy
anxiety right uh I was speaking a couple
weeks ago in Whistler and the speaker
before me was David gogins you know
David Goggins he's like the most intense
human alive crazy Navy
SEAL ninja uh and then the guy after me
was football
player pton Manning pton Manning was at
so it's like David Goggins me Payton
Manning all right right like boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom right
uh and in all honesty last year when I
spoke at
growth I I had the biggest panic attack
of my life backstage it's 10 minutes
before going live there's this big wind
up and leadup and like just bring me out
just bring me out just I can't wait to
go and and my heart's going like crazy
and
uh I just forgot how I was going to
start my
presentation right I just I just blank
have you guys had that happen where you
like you're about to get on a call or
presentation and you just you had it all
down you practiced a thousand times but
then you just go blank great that was me
just before I about to come up and speak
to you know a couple thousand people it
was the first time I was going to uh I
met Brendan so you know he invited me
out we connected through Ethan was the
first time I met him he was doing an
interview backstage and they said hey EV
I'm going to end my interview because I
want to make sure that I'm watching your
presentation like oh my gosh come on
really can't you just like have a coffee
or something backstage but it's but it's
great and he's going to give me feedback
like oh my God okay I'm I'm ready for
the feedback and so I get on Sage it and
to do my thing but just before that what
got me over it was I took a little peek
behind the curtain and I saw a bunch of
you guys and I reminded myself that I'm
not here for
me I'm here for
you right don't be so
selfish right yeah you can clut that
up it's not about me it's about the
message
and so the reason why and even this even
this lead up here I'm sting backstage
Ethan's like calming me down cuz my
heart's going crazy Brendan is talking
about the genius ideas that I told him
backstage like go oh my God Brendan look
the setup oh I better
deliver and I tell you this because I've
seen a lot of people from the Arizona
event I got stopped a lot over the past
couple days and they said Evan I loved
your your speech there was amazing like
oh thank you did you start your channel
where is it he like oh no I haven't done
it
yet like what that was how many months
ago you love my speech for what happened
and at the end of the day it's just fear
you can come up with a really logical
reason why you haven't posted yet but
really you're afraid that it's not
perfect you're afraid that nobody's
going to watch it you're afraid that
people are going to watch it you know
you're afraid you don't know the
technology you don't have the gear you
don't have the team you're just afraid
afraid afraid afraid and we cover it
with the reason why we can't do it right
but really it's just fear and so I
wanted to share my fear with you because
you might look at Dean and Brendan and
and all these mentors that you have and
they come on stage and they just look
amazing he's like well I can never be
like that but at least for my story I'm
always scared right like I'm always
playing anxious and nervous I think if
you don't have anything that makes you
anxious and nervous in your life then
you hate your
life right because then you're just
staying inside your comfort zone you
know exactly what to do you're
photocopying your life over and over and
over again and so life isn't about
having no fears it's about conquering
the fears what what Dean said yesterday
about having the courage to jump out of
the helicopter right to be like on the
edge here the helicopter or the plane
and say I'm going to jump to have the
courage to do that that's what you guys
need to do and why I share it is because
the biggest reason why you guys aren't
taking the action on the most logical
opportunity the biggest opportunity in
front of your face right now is just
because of fear whenever I get an idea I
have to do something immediately trust
your ideas believe that they're amazing
and and manifest them into the world I
love it I'm not taking it from the
approach of I want this book to be a New
York Times bestseller and I'm sitting
there visualizing my book being a New
York Times bestseller uh I'm not
visualizing myself being on Brandon
bashard stage in Puerto Rico to a couple
thousand people uh that's not the
process that I typically go through
although I'm open to that maybe being a
mistake I don't know it it's never
really felt like it's worth it I don't
know I'm sitting there I've done it many
times sitting there visualizing I've
never really felt like that made a
difference I'm open to being totally
wrong but how I do apply it and
massively seen an impact is as soon as I
get idea for something it's it's go time
trust that Vision that came to you trust
that idea that's in your head and do
something immediately about it when I
thought about the idea of of having a
house of building a custom home I then
went off and built a 5,000 ft custom
home like inside of the year we had the
whole thing done when I thought about s
silly things like I thought about having
a mannequin I was watching Green Arrow
on TV and I loved how they all had their
their mannequins when they were in their
their layer or their realm they had
their outfits their costumes on a
mannequin and I thought I feel like I'm
I'm the Green Arrow I'm I got the Deep
Hood look I could be this is this is the
believe Arrow right uh I want a
mannequin too and then inside of a week
I had my own mannequin here and so it
may seem crazy it may see Wild but
that's how I tend to operate and I think
it's amazing right now I'm thinking
about doing a 30-day challenge on my
YouTube channel my main YouTube channel
where every day for the next days I have
a series of videos to help you build a
better life so like 30 days to a better
life and it's going to be some of our
best work and I thought of the idea and
now immediately we're doing it and so
trust in the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them and I
guess manifesting them into the world I
am a th% Allin on the sitting and
visualizing the thing that I want I have
a struggle with and I'm open to um
making it better and and being changed
where I faced the hardest time with this
is my health so I broke my neck last
year right I wore this for for uh 60
days taking it off for 10 minutes a day
that was it and I had a concussion and I
had two spots in my neck that were
broken and I did some meditation with a
guy named Michael Edwards who led me
through this gu of meditation and he
helped me and he was doing it with me in
person uh over over the phone sending me
videos and first off was getting the
concussion away cuz I'd never had a
concussion before and the meditation I
found really helped the concussion the
second part was the visualization so I
have a bone in the back of my neck that
broke off so the big bone broke and is
healed the little bone just kind of
broke off like the tip like imagine I
guess the fingernail kind of hanging
loose right and it broke off and the
doctor said it's not going to come back
together and and it's not worth going
and doing surgery on it because it's not
a big deal don't worry about it
and Michael was convinced that I could
heal myself and I could make that bone
come back together and so every uh night
and every morning I would do it twice a
day meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and and you know
take some you know hand sanitizer or not
hand sanitizer take some lotion and and
you know put it on my neck and just as
I'm to get more tactical like as I'm
doing it the the bones connecting I
talked to John asaraf who is another you
know legendary expert in this field and
he's he's fully convinced that it can
come back together through visualization
and through meditation I haven't done it
yet I haven't I haven't I haven't crack
the code on how to do it I wish I did we
did x-rays UH 60 days later and it's
still just as disconnected it's still
just as didn't move a centimeter a
millimeter closer and that was honestly
a little bit uh you know negative or low
or defeating and and my motivation to do
it as intensely has has has waned I
haven't been doing it twice a day every
day I still want to believe that as
possible and I still kind of believe
that it's possible and maybe that's not
enough maybe that's a problem uh maybe
the problem was I never believed enough
that it could happen and that's why I
didn't happen so I would I would love
for that to work I would love for
meditation to work i' I've meditated
with I don't know how many different
people so many different people have
never really felt the benefit um of
having a meditation just feels like I'm
like I'm sitting down nothing wrong with
it just I don't feel extra Clarity or
anything coming out of the meditation so
I believe that has worked for other
people I believe that it can work for me
I haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where I'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why I still feature people on my channel
cuz I'm trying to learn through the
process as well but but the idea of
taking the ideas that do come to you and
taking immediate action on them right
the last letters of of law of attraction
is action doing something trusting them
I think a th% that can serve you it has
served me I know for sure can serve you
to learn to trust your ideas and do
something immediately today about it and
then build momentum towards it and that
big crazy thing that you have in your
mind may not even be that big and crazy
once you actually start taking some
action on it and so that part I'm a th%
down on and you need to do something
today in your life to
change and the other side I'm totally
open to feedback suggestions on how how
I can get better how you can get better
I think everybody can can lean in and
learn whatever they want to learn um I
had the Good Fortune of having some
great parents on the they're on the wall
behind me here I'm eight or nine years
old and those are my parents there and
they would always tell me hey you're EV
car Michael like you do anything you
believe that you can and so they helped
instill that in me um I think the whole
you know to Gary Vee's point about are
you born with it well what were you
doing at 7 years old like were you doing
lemonade stains and garage sales and
taking some initiative um but if you
weren't don't feel like oh my gosh now I
can't be an entrepreneur it's it's so
much easier now than ever to start your
own business or to lean in on the thing
for sure like I believe everybody's got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
like you're the greatest in the world at
something and you just don't believe
that you are and you don't believe in
your dreams enough to go chase them down
but you can whether it's being
entrepreneur and believe in your
business whether it's believing in your
health Journey that it's possible
whether it's you know climbing Mount
kilero or losing 100 pound or like
whatever the thing is that you'd love to
do it's it's possible people like you
have done it and that's where a lot of
people get stuck is like well it's
possible like somebody else has done it
but I can't do it because I'm whatever
and my story early with the YouTube
stuff was um I'm an introvert I'm shy so
I'm I'm not going to make it you know
but keep making content because I'm
serving but I'm I'm never going to be
the big name because I'm too introverted
and too shy and I still am by the way it
just doesn't come out when I'm doing
shows like this um but you can you know
you can whatever whatever that story is
in your head it's totally fixable and
other people you know like you have done
it and it just comes down to starting to
change what you put into your head I
think that's the biggest thing of all
that's why I make so much content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know Jay you don't
understand was impossible you know it's
like you know Jay you don't understand
I've been like this and my family has
been like this and it's just not
possible and I've tried a million things
and just nothing works and it's it's
never going to happen Jay this that's
that's who I am right if they spent a
month with you you know because you're
more confident in their ability to get
healthy than they are in their inability
to to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extented period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate it may not be your fault
but it's your responsibility it's not
your fault that you were born broke but
it's your responsibility to fix it it's
not your fault that you had no education
but it's your responsibility to learn it
it's not your fault that you had no
connections but it's your responsibility
to make them it may not be your fault
but it's your responsibility and the
sooner you accept that the sooner you're
going to win so I recently posted to my
YouTube Community tab a quote about
momentum I think people don't have
momentum and I think the path to get
momentum is to do work for free for
ideal clients until you can prove your
value and then they pay you so here's
what I wrote I wrote If you have no
momentum no traction no clients and
start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time # believe and every time I
write there's always tons of great
positive feedback but but this time
somebody wrote a a kind of negative
comment and so I wanted to read it
because it's highly applicable in this
video he said kitch I don't know about
some of your advice everything is my
fault and work for free to which I reply
yes when you Embrace those two you'll
start questioning your goals it's a hard
message to to take on right whether
everything is your fault everything is
your responsibility where you are right
now it's not about beating yourself up
it's not about saying I suck and I can't
get out it's saying listen this is what
happened to me that's the past the past
doesn't have to equal to the Future
everything that I was born into and and
the circumstances that I grew up with
they don't have to be where I go going
forward look at all your Heroes look at
the people who've made huge inroads
changed the world the people that you
look up to and aspire to be like very
few of them were born super wealthy most
of them had a worse upbringing than you
did and they could make it so why can't
you you're just locked in your story too
many people are locked into their story
they're not taking responsibility
they're not saying this is my my problem
to get out of I wasn't put here right
you've been drafted into a war that you
did not start you were put
here and you have to survive and then
you have to learn to thrive and it's
that decision that you are in charge
that you're responsible that if you go
to the mirror and you say why am I not
achieving my goals why am I not further
ahead as long as you're blaming somebody
else that might keep you comfortable
keeps you comfortable it means you don't
have to do anything right you're not
winning because your mom you know hit
you you're not winning because your dad
never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting and everybody else
around us are are doing the same thing
nobody's taking accountability
everybody's saying it's somebody else's
fault right of course it's not your
fault that you're losing cuz then you
have to do something about it and even
if you're not losing you're not hitting
the goals as hard as you should and it's
so much easier to put the blame on
somebody else and say well it's that
person's fault well really it's a person
in the mirror it's you it's me I am not
further ahead in my business on my
YouTube channel not because of the
YouTube
algorithm not because my team didn't
deliver the Right video on time me I'm
the problem it's my fault it's my
responsibility right I have to go fix it
I created this mess it's not a mess is
amazing but I'm not at 10 million
subscribers because of
me it's not that people don't want to
watch the content and people don't want
to be inspired it's me I need to get
better I need to improve and and even if
it wasn't my fault just taking that on
gives you hope that you can change it as
soon as you start putting not even the
blame I think blame is not I don't think
blame helps I don't care who's to who to
blame I care how do we fix it right if
there's a problem that happens in my
business not like who's screwed up I
don't care who's screwed up I care what
are we going to do to make sure that we
can get out of this hole and then it
doesn't happen again the next time right
taking personal accountability for where
you're at if you have not hit your goals
this good news you can but nobody's
coming to save you nothing's going to
magically change around you you you're
the change you will make the change you
can go make it happen if I want to grow
my business bigger I need to accept that
I need to grow bigger me personally EV
caricel I is my fault is my
responsibility I am to blame and use
that as a kick forward to say great like
at the beginning it may suck oh man I've
wasted how many you know weeks months
years going down the wrong path just
casting blame on other people realizing
now it's my fault okay what can you do
about it now you can change it like at
at the start the real the realization
sucks but then it's also the greatest
thing of all time if you're coming out
of from under the Rock and realize oh my
God this is all my fault that gives you
the power to fix it cuz as long as
you're relying on somebody else to do
something and they don't show up you can
constantly blame them but you're never
growing you're never accomplishing
anything cuz you're waiting for them you
have to wait for anybody it's just you
and you can fix it you have the strength
you have the power you're Michael Jordan
you have the abilities you have the
skill set and if you don't have it yet
you can develop it you can acquire it
cuz your Heroes did it and you can too
success equals habits if you are not
reaching the goals that you have for
your business and your life it's because
you are not doing the right habits
consistently I say consistently because
you are what you consistently do not
what you kind of do if you run a kind of
got to do schedule then you're going to
have a kind of okay life and a kind of
okay business business I want to change
that in this video so I live by my
calendar I think it's one of the
greatest tools you can ever have that
when you have something that you want to
accomplish in your life in your business
that it's in your calendar because if
it's not in your calendar it just
remains one of these someday I will do
something but you never actually take
action on it and and it's one of the
biggest mistakes that people make after
getting inspired motivated you watch
your video like this you go to a
conference you listen to a podcast like
that was amazing so much fire and you
might be on fire for the rest of the day
but then you don't follow through
because it's not in your calendar show
me your biggest goals in life and
business show tell me what they are if I
was going to charge $100,000 for for an
hour of coaching with you right this is
what I would focus on what are your big
goals and show me in your calendar where
you are spending your time for too many
people they don't line up for too many
people they have these Ambitions and
great ideas but they just stay ideas and
Ambitions because it's never actually in
your calendar and so if you don't put
the big things in your calendar you'll
never accomplish them the little things
will take over your life for too many of
us the little things have taken over and
it's not that they're not important cuz
they are but small in importance and so
you can tell yourself like I did so much
look at how much I did but then you look
back on the week it's like what did I
actually do I was busy the whole week
but did I move forward any of my goals
or Ambitions probably not this is the
problem so for me I like having
different things on different days a
Tuesday I I make videos this is this is
a Tuesday for me this video may not be
released on a Tuesday but I'm recording
on a Tuesday cuz Tuesday I am making
YouTube videos cuz I want to grow my
YouTube impact CU I want to reach 500
million people a billion people right I
want to reach the world and I think
YouTube's the best way to do it right
now and so great it's amazing to have
that ambition show me in your calendar
where you're spending your time well all
day Tuesday I'm making videos
Wednesday's my project day Thursday is
my public facing interview day Friday is
my CEO day Saturday is my fun day with
my wife right this impacts your personal
life as well Saturday I'm I'm planning
the entire day for my wife that has fun
surprises where there's no work
happening not even going to Costco like
no Costco is not fun for me so we're not
going to Costco Sunday is family admin
day where that's Costco day that's bu
buy a new couch day that's do the
laundry day that's whatever needs to be
done for the family and then Monday is
mentoring day spending that with my team
right I look at my calendar and this is
what you can do look at your calendar
every week and see what's ahead for the
week is there a structure to it if you
looked at that calendar and stepped
above it and said if I did these things
will I move closer to accomplishing my
goals when I make progress It's not that
you're going to hit your goal by just
spending a week working on something you
won't but will you make progress towards
it is there growth is there achievement
happening and from too many people it's
a no and I think you should change that
nobody wakes up every day and says this
is going to be the greatest day ever not
Dan loock not Evan carmichle not Tony
Robbins nobody you wake up and you're
tired and you have stuff in your eyes
and you have lines on your face from the
pillows the difference between
successful people is that they demand
Excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do daily the
problem is that thinking that these
people are different that if you're not
waking up with tons of motivation ready
to take on the day that something is
wrong with you the only thing that's
wrong with you is you don't have the
habits that set you up for Success every
single day and today I want to change
that so I have a 5S morning routine that
I go through every single day that sets
me up for Success that demands
Excellence I'm going to share with you
guys today the first s is sing the
fastest way to change your state is to
put on music the fastest way to go from
feeling low energy tired bored into an
energy of I am ready to go is music put
on the song not that makes you feel the
current way that you're feeling this is
where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're going to put on really
mellow slow music what does that do it
keeps you in the same state that you're
in it it keeps you exactly where you are
what you want to do is put on the music
for how you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody there's a
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're going
to dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
going to start builting up the lyrics
that may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like to
dance something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on as the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
set in the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also signifying that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving the condo the apartment the home
you're leaving what happened last night
and you're ready to go off and start the
day this is especially important if
you're working from home because it's
easy to have your you know office right
next to your bedroom or maybe your
office is your bedroom and carry that
bedroom energy that tired I just woke up
I want to stay in bed I want to sleep
energy into your work and you won't do
great things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work so having some
kind of ritual that splits up sleeping
energy to I'm ready to go energy makes a
big difference and I find the easiest
way to do it is to get outside and get
some sun bonus points if you're in a
condor apartment to take the stairs
instead of the elevator s number three
is sord and this is the most important
thing for me if you only take one of the
five I think this is the most important
one to take what is the thing that makes
you sore every day what's the thing that
makes you feel alive bold confident what
is that and put it into your morning
routine at some point in your life you
felt bold you felt Unstoppable you felt
confident it's happened to everybody the
problem is you don't feel that way
consistently every day you go through
these bursts these moments of man I
could do such amazing things but then
the next day you wake up and you're a
different person you're back to the I
don't know if I can do it I don't know
who am I to go do this crazy thing
that's the problem so whatever the thing
is that makes you feel like you can come
alive that gives you that boldness and
confidence plan it with intention every
single day into your morning routine for
me what I do is I record a message on my
phone to to Instagram to my stories to I
put it to LinkedIn and Twitter right now
I'm putting it everywhere but I need to
make a message so I I think of somebody
that I helped yesterday I think of
somebody who commented on a video who I
met in person who I coached on my
Instagram live somebody that I helped
yesterday and then I make a message
channeling that person I won't say the
person's name but I I have them in my
head that I need to remind myself that
the work that I do is important it's
easy to get lost in numbers it's it's
hard to imagine that two to 300,000
people watched my videos yesterday
that's crazy it's a wild number right
it's wild it's hard to like what is it
even mean I don't know I'm just sitting
here talking to a camera in my office
and two to 300,000 people are watching
my videos it's crazy I need to think
down to the actual person I need to
think about an individual that this
matters to somebody that the work I do
really means something to them and then
I need to record a message and share
that helps me sore and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the inpressive videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be part of every
morning routine for other people might
be meditating that might be watching a
video it might be reading a book
listening to a podcast I don't care what
the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth s for
me is sweat this is just about being
healthy having a healthy lifestyle and I
want to do something that makes me sweat
so whether it's a hit workout a cardio
workout a weights workout I put that
into my daily routine cuz I want to bust
the sweat and I want to stay healthy
into my 40s which is coming up and then
into my 50s and Beyond and then the last
s for me is scare I want to do something
every day that scares me what I'm doing
right now is to take a cold shower so
after sweating I need to have a shower
don't want to show up to work all smelly
and so I hop in the shower but right
away start turning the colder and colder
and colder and colder and colder and
then right at the very end I go all the
way cold and I freeze and even just
thinking of it right
now it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way right from the beginning I find
really helps me you are not that
different than your Heroes the people
who you look up to respect watch their
videos of listen to their podcasts read
their books there's not that big a Chasm
between who they are and who you are
there's a tendency to look at these
people who had ginormous success and say
Well they're just built differently
they're wired differently I'm not like
them and that mindset that way of
thinking for you to say that I'm just so
different from them is keeping you safe
and small and not realizing your
potential the only difference between
Your Heroes and you is the willingness
and ability to step into the discomfort
they were willing will to do it you
haven't yet and we're going to change it
in this video so on Monday I was meeting
with Alex who helps me run tronto Dan
salsa and he's an amazing entrepreneur
he's got tons of heart and energy and
love and care and he's been struggling
to stay consistent he's he's working
from home right now we've got Corona
virus you know shut down lock down he
hasn't been on his regular routine and I
was pushing him on Monday to to get back
on the routine let's go basic things
like clean up your apartment and and
make proper food for yourself and stay
on your workout regimen this should be
the time where you stay disciplined and
his response was I'm not I'm not getting
it I'm not I'm not hearing I can't
connect to the advice because I feel
like you're just different than me
you're just wired differently and that
is the biggest
copout because it allows you to play
small it allows you to look at people
who who are doing the thing it allows
you to look at me or Lisa or anybody who
you look up to right Steve or AP or
Kanye or Howard L you look at these
people that you love and respect and say
well that they were just so magical and
so different and that's the reason why
they won and I I'm just never I'm never
going to be like that cuz they're built
differently you're giving yourself an
out you're giving yourself the biggest
excuse and biggest out that most people
fall into that trap of and I told Alex
dude there is no difference between you
and me not on this the difference is my
willingness to step into discomfort my
willingness to say this thing that's
happening right now is the greatest
you're s there thinking this is the
hardest time of all I'm thinking this is
the greatest that's the difference the
mindset shift the training that's got in
to making that mindset shift happens is
the only difference not that I'm better
or born different or have any other set
of circumstances that is preventing you
from winning like me and so I told him
this is a muscle that you build starting
today you start building that muscle
right I'm just a little bit further
ahead I've done more more work in the
weight room of of the mindset right and
so it's unfair to compare where you're
at right now to where I'm at and it's
unfair to compare where you're at you
guys watching to where Lisa's at or
Steve Jobs or somebody else because
you're not comparing their beginning and
you might be at the beginning right now
and so it starts today and I told Alec
it starts today what can you do today to
make yourself proud of your effort the
problem is you're not proud of your
effort the problem is you might be
posting some things Instagram and saying
look at what I did today but you're
going to sleep at night you didn't pass
the pillow test
saying you're proud of yourself what do
you need to do today to be proud of your
effort he said I got to I got to clean
up my condo cuz it's a giant mess like
great go clean up your condo and it took
him way longer than he thought it was
going to take but he did it and then you
know what magical things happened he
started making calls to the people he
need to make calls to he started making
videos for the videos he need to make
videos for he started to have more
energy and enthusi and and hope and
belief and confidence cuz he did the
difficult thing now that's just one day
it's every day deciding to do that same
thing over and over and over and over
and over again and then that's how you
build the muscle you don't build giant
muscles by going to the gym once and
working your face off it's every single
day going to the gym comparison to other
people I think is actually a good thing
I think you need it I think it helps you
I think it serves you the problem is
most people look at other people start
feeling insecure and then kick
themselves down the key is to kick
yourself forward not down but you need
that kick otherwise you stay where you
are this is one of the reasons why I
love model success why I created all my
YouTube channels and all the content
that I've done and have the people
behind me on the wall because I love
looking at other people I love learning
from other people I love seeing somebody
do amazing things and say that's what's
possible this is what's possible I look
at Les Brown as an example and I think
he's the greatest speaker of all time at
least that I've I've seen I don't maybe
maybe the ancient Greeks were better I
don't know but but Les Brown modern era
on video I think is the greatest speaker
and I look at that and say that's what's
possible not that I can't do that here's
what most people do they look at Les
Brown and say well I can't do that and
then they start feeling insecure and I'm
just I'm just an impostor trying to be
like that now and then they quit and
then they feel they feel low self-esteem
when they and they beat themselves up
over it because they're not less brown I
look at last Brown and say that's what's
possible this is what this is what
humans can actually accomplish and
Achieve I want some of that I want to
get better I want to drive and improve
not to be the next L Brown but be the
best me but this is what's possible I
look at David gogins Man David Goggins
look he came out of nowhere who was
David Goggins did you guys know David
Goggins 5 years ago no he blew up out of
nowhere because of the passion and
intensity and truth of his message right
I love that and it's easy to say and
look at that well look at how passionate
David gogin is and look how he blew up I
can never do that I'm not as strong as
him I'm not as crazy as him I don't have
the same mindset of him and so I can't
do that and you compare yourself to
goggin and then you say well I can't I
can't and so you don't start that's the
problem you should look at goggin and
say look at what's possible you could
come from nowhere nobody knowing who you
are and in a short amount of time blow
up because you have a message that
matters you can look at how passionate
he is about his message every video he
got insane passion right this guy he's
not going to give you nice hugs and
compliments but he he cares about his
message right you can see that and you
could take that as as what's possible
you can you can care deeply about your
message too and model David goggin and
and apply that to make your message
stronger and better I think if you just
were competing with yourself I think
you're actually going to suck I think I
think if you're the best at something
and you don't have any competition I
think you actually suck uh being the big
fish in a small pond actually limits a
lot of creativity uh limits your ability
to go off and Crush things I think I
think it is I think when you even even
in animals when you see animals going up
against each other in a in a race when
when somebody's close you work a little
bit harder right I think I think we need
that in our ecosystem the key though
again is to make sure you're kicking
yourself forward to say this is what is
possible not this person is so much
better than me I suck feeling insecure
feeling depressed you need the kick just
make sure you're kicking yourself
forward not down do you feel like some
people are just that entrepreneurs are
born I know you say that everybody has
enough to serve but you think there's
some people that are just more prone or
um more gifted or more capable when it
comes to um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things how
do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you you like
I like this and then you dop into it a
lot of times you can't think your way
through these things because chances are
the thing that you should be doing is
very different than what is in your
family and in your circle most of the
time the thing that you should be doing
with your life is very different than
what your parents did or what your
brothers or sisters or cousins or
Community or church people there are
doing yeah and so it takes courage to go
off and do it right if if you're if
you're working with women who have a
belief system of well women are supposed
to be this way way but then they know
that like I don't want to be that I'm
I'm greater than that I know I'm greater
than that right yeah to have the courage
to chase that dream down I think is
important and that's where I think
people like you are a voice what matters
is that you're productive that you get
results that you stop wasting time too
many people default to thinking that if
they just wake up an hour earlier
they're going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
going to be more productive in a 17-hour
day when you have less sleep so this is
a interesting message and timing for me
right now because I I love beating the
Sun up I love it I I love working I like
it's my default state if nah is off on a
Friday night with her friends or
something 80% chance I'm working I love
it I look forward to it when I go close
my eyes I can't wait for it to be the
next day like I'm pumped to go off and
do the work I recently did a sleep study
and my doctor was concerned I wasn't
getting enough quality sleep so I went
to go do a sleep study and the doctor
after going through the results uh told
me that I need to be sleeping 8 and 1/2
hours to 9 hours a night and it and it
like super disappointed me 8 and 1 half
hours to 9 hours are you kidding me I
I'm trying to go from I was trying to go
from 88: to 7:00 I was waking up after 8
hours sleep and and feeling still a
little bit tired and so that's why my
doctor recommended even going to the
sleep study and I'm trying to figure out
how do I hack it to get down to 7 and
still be fully functional not not be you
know lazy and slow and not having my
cognition and uh yeah he said I need to
be sleeping 8 and 1 half to 9 hours a
night he said is that is that normal
like are you not worried he's like no as
long as you're under 10 it's normal
people range from 6 to 10 and and
they're totally fine like this sucks I
mean I'm not happy about it I'm still
looking at how can I hack my sleep more
and we've tried a lot I have the chili
pad we've got you know meditation before
sleeping and I'm lying on the bed of
nails with the thing behind me the
pillow the nail pillow uh no you know
phones or computers x amount of time
before going to bed red light filters on
everything red lights no lights at all
in the place right like just these
little red lights glowing around after
sun after Sunset lots of it cool down
the temperature I don't know all of it
don't eat past 8:00 no caffeine past 2
o00 all of it I'm doing all of that
stuff all of it right plus probably a
lot more stuff I've I've studied and
hacked away I still believe there's a
lot more hacking I still want to get it
from 9 to 7 but but if I'm at 9 and I
need n9ine I think you should get nine
I'm at the point now where if I wake up
and the Sun is still uh not up I stay in
bed and and that's actually uh boosting
of confidence is like okay so I wake up
and sun is hasn't come up yet okay this
is hard this is difficult it's difficult
for me to not get out of bed I'm going
to stay in bed just because now I'm I'm
a I'm a weird duck so maybe this works
for maybe it doesn't but I was having a
great conversation with uh Jeremy who's
on my team who who I've invested in his
business he's helping companies scale
their YouTube channels and he was going
through the same thing where he was
feeling a little tired in the afternoon
he wanted to nap on some afternoons and
that's never been me so dude you need to
just try uh waking up without an alarm
and normally he's up at 4:30 in the
morning or something um so just wake up
without an alarm and see how it goes and
he ended up sleeping for 9 hours and
hatting hating himself for doing it he's
like dude maybe you need 9 hours like
much more important than that extra hour
or two is what are you doing during the
day if if you're losing energy during
the day and you want to nap every
afternoon you're not being productive
like there's no way sleep and be
productive you need sleep to win I think
everybody should get a sleep test I
think it's a brutal experience you don't
you barely sleep right when you're there
you got stuff up your nose and a million
sensors all over you but to know how
much sleep you actually need uh and
making sure that you're productive
during the time that you are awake
that's the most important thing that you
are productive during the time that you
awake is way more important than if you
wake up before the sun gets out you
haven't said that this is the thing this
is what I have to accomplish today this
is the mission that I am on and nothing
is going to stop me if you don't learn
to focus on what's important to you
you'll never do important things and
live your life reacting to what's
important to other people instead so I
recently started a new business with one
of my thought Leadership Academy
students Jeremy he came to my event last
year I was thinking about him on my tour
this year and said I want to start a
business with Jeremy around YouTube
Consulting I get asked a lot hey Evan
can you check out my channel hey Evan
can I work with you Heen can I hire you
for XYZ looking at my channel giving me
ideas mentoring guiding me and it's just
not the business that I want to be in
but it is a business and so I thought
Jeremy Jeremy's going to come on board
he's going to do it now when I recruited
him and called him he was not a YouTube
expert and I gave him the homework and
said listen if you want to do this
business together it's it's got to be
important to you I'm halfway through my
trip on my tour I'm coming back in a
month and a half here's what I need you
to know by the end of the month and a
half and I gave him resources I gave him
videos I gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this and then when I come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business and he did he focused he made
it his priority he knew nothing about
this and all of a sudden he became an
expert by every day all day long
grinding to learn by by researching
everybody who is an expert at this
understanding their methodologies their
best practices looking through all my
videos my thumbnails my strategies all
the things that I've talked about in the
past digesting it kind of like the
Matrix when Neo's in The Matrix and and
he now we can learn Kung Fu and now he
learns how to fly a helicopter all of
that stuff that's basically what he did
and when it came back in a month and a
half I put him to the test and said hey
let's do two free calls we'll take two
people from my community and say hey
free free free call let's go and he blew
me away with how much he knew because he
focused on it here's a guy who went from
knowing almost zero to now being an
expert to be able to really help give
value to people and now when we're
looking at new people coming in I I
barely have to do anything because he
already knows what I'm going to say he
already knows he's already done the work
he's done the research because he spent
that time on focused effort and this is
where I think a lot of people feel like
they're never going to win because you
may not have had the expertise you don't
have the education it doesn't take long
to become an expert it's just focused
work that you're passionate about
focused work you could quickly become in
a matter of months an expert at
something if you just focus in on it and
dedicate your life to that thing that
you love you can easily pass people who
are experts at something who don't love
their thing but because you're willing
to take it on you're willing to absorb
think about when you went to school how
much of the information you had in your
head but you had to read over the page
four times so you write the same page
four five six times cuz you got lost you
got distracted that's not focused work
cuz you don't love that thing I think
judging yourself is actually great I
think you need it I think it's healthy I
think people should be harder on
themselves the problem is people can't
handle being even a little bit harder on
themselves because they're already at
the point of being depressed or even
suicidal the secret starts with
self-love your self love has to equal
your self-criticism you have to be your
biggest fan as well as your biggest
critic the root problem isn't judging
yourself it's not loving yourself one of
the challenges to think of being human
is we are social animals we're social
creatures we rely on each other we need
each other we want to belong we want to
be part of tribes we want to do things
together right we want to be around
other
people so that makes us want to fit in
and that makes us play small worry about
what people think about us because if we
don't do the thing that they want us to
do they might judge us and kick us out
of the tribe the good news is there's so
many different tribes you can do now
right there's so many different people
that it may not be your your friends
that you have right now may not be your
parents or your family or your community
right now but whatever you want to do
there is a group of people who believe
the same things you believe who think
the same way you think and I think one
of the healthiest things that you can do
is whenever you feel the eyes of
potential judgment for something that
you want to do you have to go off into
do it just to show yourself when you
have lost control of your outcomes
remember you can still control your
actions you are not in control of the
market of your customers of your Revenue
but you can still control how and where
you spend your time and if you're
feeling overwhelmed it's because you
feel like you have no control we're
going to fix that in this video so as
I'm recording this video we're in the
middle of the Corona virus outbreak
we're in quarantine I'm here in my place
in Toronto Canada filming content like I
normally do but my business is hurting
all the businesses that I'm involved in
are hurting so if you look at my YouTube
channel is an example the views were
down the the revenue rates on
Advertising is way down cuz people
aren't advertising right now uh my
speaking business is zero I'm I was
supposed to be speaking multiple times
this month it's all to zero my book tour
not happening and so all of this chaos
to look at my Toronto dance salsa
business where we teach people how to
dance salsa the largest dance school in
Canada maybe North America for salsa
dancing and shut down zero nothing not
happening right I mean we can't have
classes during Coronavirus people are
not allowed to touch so our business was
shut down by the government and that
sucks it's easy to get lost it's easy to
to get involved in chaos and say oh my
God this is It's All Over everything's
spiraling out of control I can't control
what happens with Corona virus I can't
control what's happening with my
students and whether they're going to
come back or not all I can control is
what I do all I can control is how I
show up every day I can still make
videos I can still plan I can still
create content I can still reach out to
my team and and ask how they're doing
and motivate and Inspire them I could
still do activities every day where
people get losses getting overwhelmed by
just staying in their head saying oh my
God this is never going to work out I
don't know what to do and you're just
stuck in a spiral of thinking instead of
actually creating and getting lost in a
new cycle in seeing what's happening and
checking in 80 times a day to see what
the new death toll numbers are coron
virus doesn't help you there's one thing
to be informed and and it's great to be
informed and you need to make informed
decisions amazing but to be overwhelmed
by it to Cloud your thinking so that all
you're doing is thinking and not have
enough action that just creates a really
strong negative cycle and spiral
downwards because when you're feeling
out of control the way out of it is to
control your actions again to control
your thinking again but if you're not
actually taking any action then you
never actually solve the problem and so
it's doing the best you can with what
you have I am still in control of my
time I can still wake up today and make
videos for you I can still wake up today
and do my Instagram stories I can still
wake up today and plan what we're going
to do with my Sala business once we get
out of the Corona virus because this is
not going to last forever you can still
wake up today and choose to be
productive on the things that will best
Drive value for your business and for
your customers today your brain is
keeping you afraid and preventing you
from achieving everything that you want
because your brain is practical it's
logical it only understands a world that
currently exists and if you want to
change the world and you don't learn
learn how to hack your brain you are
going to play scared for life so I was
trying to think about as I was watching
this video what the when was the last
time that I felt really overwhelmingly
scared like I might not be able to do
this I can't do this I'm not capable I'm
not worthy I I don't think I I'm I'm
going to deliver a good job and the the
only idea that came to mind recently of
a big thing was when I was speaking at
the event in Phoenix and I was invited
by Brendan bashard and the graziosi and
I was speaking to their event and before
me was Eric Thomas on day one and I was
the last speaker on the last day and I
remember the day of I was pacing
backstage about an hour 45 minutes
before the actual event I'm I'm there
I'm pacing I'm walking back and forth
Brendon brashard said he's going to
watch my entire speech and and give me
feedback after which only adds to the
pressure and there was a moment where I
blanked out there was a moment maybe 10
minutes before I went on stage I'm
standing backstage and I blank out I
blank like I don't I don't even know
what I'm going to talk what am I going
to talk about right now I don't even
know what I'm going to talk about right
now it's been a long time since I felt
that level
of desperation insecurity overwhelm
because usually as soon as something as
soon as I hear myself saying this is
hard this is difficult uh I I said okay
let's go do it the challenge in this
situation was I couldn't just get up on
stage whenever I
wanted and so I'm I'm left sitting there
walking backstage thinking oh my God oh
my God oh my God what if I don't win
what if I don't what if I don't give a
great performance what if I let
everybody down which is my greatest fear
what if I let the audience down and
Brendan down and Dean down and I totally
I just forgot what I'm going to say how
do I even start my presentation I'm G to
wake I'm gonna I'm G to get up on stage
and just face
plant it was
this I don't know minute of just real
desperation a feeling like oh my gosh
I'm going to get up there and
suck I don't know what I'm going to
say and then the thing that caught me
and I'm so grateful that it did like the
training the training this is how you
train yourself the training came in I
said what are you doing you're Evan
Carmichael let's
go and that may sound super
egotistical but I think I think the
self-criticism only works when it's
based off a foundation of self- love
love like I think you need to celebrate
yourself more I think you need to
recognize yourself more not bragging on
social media that you did some fake goal
that you know didn't take a lot of work
but you might get some accolades for
from your friends and people following
you I'm talking about what do you tell
yourself like when you walk past
yourself in the mirror do you see a rock
star do you see a stud do you see
somebody who's going to go change the
world most people is no and it's and if
it's a yes it's not consistent and so I
think doing the work to tell yourself
that you're amazing I I think that
should be a default answer every time
you're nervous is to say I'm fill in
your name I'm you your name
right I'm having Carmichael let's
go and that motivated me to then
instantly remember what the thing was it
wasn't I forgot what I was going to say
I was just too stressed out and blocked
that I couldn't actually get through to
what I was supposed to go out and talk
about and so that shift in my state um
by telling myself I'm Evan Carmichael
let's go
allowed me to connect to it and then go
off and and deliver U at least what I
thought was a pretty great speech and
event you are a product of your
environment the people around you are
keeping you exactly where you are and if
you love where you are then keep with
those people but if you want more out of
life if you've got bigger dreams bigger
Ambitions then you're going to have to
let some of those takers go now I've
been pretty fortunate that I haven't had
any real takers in a long time in my
life but here's the thing it's it's easy
to recognize the people who are really
negative in your life and want to
eliminate them but then once you've done
that you'll still find that there's this
middle ground there's these people who
bring you energy who are amazing who
lift you up who are awesome to be around
and there are people who are negative
that you cut out of your life but then
there's that middle ground of people who
they're just okay they're not bad
they're not great it's just okay and if
you want to raise the quality of your
life if you want to raise your standards
you can't be hanging around at least
spending most of your time with people
who make you feel just okay so I got
back from an event with Tony Robbins uh
not that long ago I think it was last
year when I went with my friend Mark
drer
and Tony at the end of his events has
you do this firew walk and he lays out
these you know coals these hot burning
coals across a parking lot and you have
to walk uh walk over it and he has you
seeing Cool Moss cool Moss and it gets
you all excited and Ed up to to cross
the walk and the idea is you're doing
something that you're afraid of you're
doing something that you're scared of
and to show yourself that you're capable
of doing difficult things Mark and I
decided to actually skip the firewalk
because we rushed home and I did the
real firewalk which was in my life
letting go of a number of people who
were just okay it wasn't that they were
bad or toxic or big takers from my life
it was just okay and I realized if I'm
spending all my time on things that are
just okay things people projects ideas
that are just okay that make you feel
just okay right it's good as the enemy
of great if it's really bad you're going
to let it go but if it's good you just
keep it around and then suddenly the
good becomes your standard your good
becomes acceptable when did good become
acceptable that's what you need to draw
the line in the sand and say the ideas
that are just good I need to eliminate
from my life the people that are just
good I need to either eliminate or spend
less time with them to leave room for
the things that are great extraordinary
excellent raising your standards making
you believe more in yourself and your
capabilities and so coming back from
that event not even it was on that day
not even coming back it was on that day
I went back to my airb B with Mark and
and I let go of M multiple people in my
life and not let go and say you suck
just basically moving on and and that
allowed me to have a lot more momentum
now now I had a lot more free time that
allowed me to focus on things that would
build me up that would explode my growth
forward and it's been a crazy year it's
been a it's been basically a year year
November 2018 was when that happened so
now it's been almost a full year uh I
guess by the time this video comes out
it's been a full year wow that's crazy
it's been a full year since that
happened you have to let go of the
takers first and then you have to start
thinking about are the people around you
just good are your ideas just good and
slowly start getting rid of those ones
the projects the tasks look at your
calendar what's just good in your life
and get rid of it and leave room and
focus on the things that are
extraordinary that fill you up that
build you up that make you feel amazing
because you deserve it and all of your
great work all of your great activities
all of your great momentum your great
impact is going to come on the other
side of doing amazing things you will
never create something amazing when
you're working on something good when
you feel good and definitely not when
you feel
bad because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more rules from Gary
vaynerchuk check the video right there
next to me I thank you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I don't think anybody can work
hard hard unless they like it I was the
least hardworking student I was selling
lemonade and shoveling snow and washing
cars and selling baseball cards every
day